this one is from
casa la marca oh hello what about that
casa malacca and he says when aragon is
throwing kimberly and helms deep
and he says
don't tell the elf
love that all right what have i got
i mean a classic one here from
sarah luisa lafaye
um
gandalf falling into the uh balrog's pit
fly
pretty good
i like it yeah
and um
and you've heard the theory that um
gandalf was actually telling us to get
the eagles at that point he was he was
about to tell us and then he had to
fight the balrog and then he says oh
fire fools it's an interesting thing
i've heard that before right hold on and
we need to put the eagle thing to bed at
some point but maybe that's a later
never take an eagle a bed no never the
talons will
rip your eyes out but everyone has said
to us over the years why didn't frodo
even just frodo just get picked up by an
eagle flown over yeah doom thing and
dropped it it's not how it works no it's
not as easy as no it's not for one thing
there's no drama then well you can say
that about any show it's a sentence but
also we needed the fellowship as it were
to create so many distractions so that
sauron didn't know which halfling he was
looking for and if his eye was looking
right at an eagle flying across he don't
get rid of that
harmonize with me and hold me back all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your boy's the baby you're my pearl